katie throws a ball in the air for her
dog to chase
the function f models the height of the
ball in meters as a function of time in
seconds after katie threw it and we
could see that right over here this is
our function f so at time t equals zero
the height looks like it's a couple of
meters and then as we go forward in time
to a little under two and a half seconds
the ball is going up and then after a
little under two and a half seconds the
ball starts going down and after
by the time you get to five seconds or
close to five seconds it looks like the
ball is on the ground its height is zero
meters
so then they ask us
which of these statements are true
choose all that apply so pause this
video and see if you can work it out
all right now let's look through the
choices so the first one says katie
threw the ball from a height of five
meters so let's see if that
bears
fruit or disease that see if that's true
so if she threw it from a height of five
meters that means that the y-intercept
would have been at five meters at time t
equals zero would have been at a height
of five meters clearly that is not the
y-intercept it looks like she threw it
from a height of maybe one and a half or
two meters so
i'm assuming that katie is not five
meters tall so she wasn't on a ladder or
anything she just threw it from her
regular height and so we can rule out
this first choice
the second one says at its highest point
the ball was about 31 meters above the
ground let's see if that is true
so the highest point is right over here
and yeah that looks that looks about 31
meters so i like that choice
so i will select that one
the ball was in the air for about two
and a half seconds
so we can clearly see that that is not
in not the case the ball was going up
for about two and a half seconds but
then it was going down for roughly
another two and a half seconds and so it
was actually in the air for almost five
seconds so i would
i would rule
this one out
the ball reached its highest point in
the air about two and a half seconds
after katie threw it
so let's see after katie two and a half
seconds after katie threw the ball it's
right over there it looks like it
reached its highest point a little bit
before that but they said about so
they're speaking in rough terms so i
think that statement can be true it's
about it's about two and a half seconds
if they said exactly two and a half
seconds i wouldn't have selected it
because it seems like it happened at
like 2.45 seconds or something like that
but there you go those are the ones that
that seem true